[موسيقى]
سيدي رئيس الحكومه هل ثمت خطا تو الاعتراف
به والتعبير عن ندمك عليه الان امام
الشعب هذا سؤال طرحه احد الصحفيين على
نتنياهو خلال مؤتمره الصحفي الاخير ولم
يكن اغرب من السؤال سوى
الاجابه انا اقاتل حماس وانتم تقاتلني حين
ترغب انت بالاعتراف باخطائك على الملا
سيسعدني ان اسمع واذا اراد البعض التماس
العذر لنتنياهو سيقول انه من كثره اخطائه
لم يعرف بايها
يبدا فقبل اسبوع اثار هذا الرجل عاصفه وسط
طوفان سياسي تشهده اسرائيل فقد توجه متن
ياهو انجلمان وهو مراقب الدوله لقاده كافه
الاجهزه الامنيه والعسكريه مطالبا اياهم
بمعلومات سريه ووثائق في اطار تحقيقه في
احداث السابع من اكتوبر وما قبلها وعاصفه
هو الوصف الذي اختارته صحيفه يدعوت
احرونوت لردود مسؤولين في الاجهزه الامنيه
والعسكريه والذين اتهموه بانه استبق
الامور وبدا بالتحقيق حتى قبل ان تضع
الحرب اوزارها لاجل تحميل مسؤوليه اخفاق
السابع من اكتوبر للمستوى العسكري وتبييض
صفحه السياسيين ولا سيما نتنياهو الذي حمل
مع بدايه الحرب قاده الاجهزه العسكريه
والاستخباري هم وحدهم مسؤوليه اخفاقات
السابع من اكتوبر وان كان تراجع عن ذلك
لاحقا ولذلك لم يتاخر رئيس المعارضه يا
اير لابيد في شن ما وصفته معاريف بانه
هجمه على انجلمان واتهامه بانه يعمل عند
نتنياهو واليوم يجد نتنياهو نفسه في قلب
عاصفه يحاول صد رياحها حتى من جانب اعضاء
حزبه ووزراء الائتلاف الحكومي الذي يقوده
وعن استطلاعات الراي التي تجعله صاحب
الاحتمال الاقل في ان يقود حزبه الليكود
في الانتخابات القادمه فحدث ولا حرج فهذا
بنفير وزير الامن الداخلي هاجمه بسبب
طريقه ادارته للحرب وتقليص القوات في غزه
والموافقه على دخول الادويه لسكانها دون
فحصها وهذا جالنت وزير الدفاع وعضو
الليكود يغضب ويقاطع اجتماعا لمجلس وزراء
الحرب بعد تفاقم خلافاته مع نتنياهو
وانتقاد غياب اي تصور سياسي عنده لمرحله
ما بعد الحرب عدا عن تصريح جالنت الاخير
بان غزه يعيش فيها فلسطينيون ولذلك يحكمها
الفلسطينيون وهو ما اعتبره كثيرون تغريدا
خارج سربي نتنياهو الذي طالما عزف على لحن
لا فتح ستان ولا حماس ستان لحن يبدو انه
يطرب حلفائه بنفير و سموتريتش وان اعتبره
كثيرون في الداخل والخارج صوتا نشازا
وطالبوا بعزله اما انصار نتنياهو في مجلس
الحرب الذي يقوده فلم يلتمسوا له العذر
حتى هم فهذا جادي ايزنكوت يصرح ان نتنياهو
هو المسؤول الاول عن كل ما حصل في السابع
من
اكتوبر وعلى الحدود الشماليه وصل سخط
رؤساء الس سلطات على نتنياهو وحكومته
مبلغا دعا موشي دافيدوفيتش وهو رئيس
منتداهم لان يقول لن تسكتو بالاموال
الدوله تفقد الشمال بسبب الظروف القاسيه
التي يعيشها من تم اخلاهم والعجز عن
التصدي لصواريخ حزب الله وصواريخ حماس لكن
بالنسبه لنتنياهو ليت الامر يقتصر على
السياسيين فها هي عائلات الاسر
الاسرائيلين ايضا تتهمه صراحه بانه يعرقل
اتفاقيات لاطلاق سراح احبائهم ليبقى
متربعا على عرش
الحكم وحتى اصدقائه خلف البحار بات وقع
كلامهم اشد مضاده عليه اذ يتزايد الشعور
بالاحباط منه عند الامريكيين والاعتقاد
بانه يدير الحرب حسب مصالحه
الشخصيه واذا لم يكن كل هذا الاصطفاف ضد
نتنياهو كافيا لينتبه ففي لاهاي اصطف طاقم
عريض من القضاه في محكمه عدل دوليه جرت
اليها اسرائيل اساسا بسبب تصريحات اطلقها
نتنياهو ووزراء حكومته وامام كل ذلك يرد
نتنياهو بان يظهر في قاعده عسكريه ويدلي
بتصريح مقتضب لم ياتي على اي جديد امام
طائره مقاتله ربما قصد ان يظهر بمثل قوتها
وعنفوانها وتحت وطاه كل هذه الازمات يبدو
الخط مقطوعا بين نتنياهو وكل من حوله
وربما حتى مع اسمه نفسه فنتنياهو بالعبريه
معناه عطيه الله عطيه لا يبدو ان احدا
يريدها